Speaker 1: I have to admit, when when I am taking
pleasure in someone else's misery, I admit it to
you guys. I do. I don't hide that Donald Trump's
truth. Social is collapsing South Central. They
owe more than $1,000,000 to their web hosting
company. And according to Tom Bud Gioni for
Salon.com, the platform is rapidly heading for
bankruptcy. I admit it. I am taking pleasure
in this. I am Donald Trump's truth. Social is
facing some very serious financial problems. They
reportedly owe the web hosting company that they
use more than $1,000,000 already. They are having
problems with some of their intellectual property
trademark registrations. In a filing this week,
Digital World Acquisition, which planned to take
the Trump Media and technology group public,
is now issuing warnings about what the future may
bring. Isn't that sad? Quote, The company warned
this week that its businesses could be damaged if
Trump becomes less popular or there are further
controversies that damage its credibility. The
company has seen its stock price plunge nearly 75%
since its March peak and reported in a filing last
week. It lost $6.5 million in the first half of
the year. The company's financial base has begun
to erode. The Trump Company stopped paying Right
Forge, a conservative web hosting service in March
and now owes it more than $1,000,000. This is a
I'm going to tell you guys, this is a delightful
fete. And I have to tell you, I'm not taking
pleasure in this because I want some authoritarian
censorship of the platform. I'm taking pleasure
in it because it's the free market. Deciding
the platform is so lame, no one cares. It's
not popular. Producer Pat mentioned on the bonus
show you. Yesterday that many people have accounts
only to be able to see what other people are
posting, not because they want to post anything,
just because you have to have an account. At last
we checked in order to see the things that are
posted. Here's a report from MSNBC about this.
Speaker 3: Former President Trump's social media
platform is facing money problems right now.
True social doesn't have a guaranteed source of
income and it doesn't get any. It could go bust.
A new SEC filing from the company planning to take
to social public is warning of damages to the
already slowing business. If, oh, president,
quote, becomes less popular or there are further
controversies that damage his credibility. Now,
this comes as the platform has reportedly stopped
paying its Web hosting service and now owes
it more than $1 million, this according to Fox
Business. Let's bring in NBC News senior reporter
Ben Collins. And here's why we're bringing in
Ben, because you're an expert on the Internet.
Speaker 1: This is really the best.
Speaker 3: So my first question is just
how popular or not popular is truth, social?
I mean, does the former president have reason
to be concerned?
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaker 2: It's not popular at all. Let's be
real about this. Donald Trump is the primary
user on that platform and even he only gets
a few thousand likes or what they call them,
recruits or posts.
Speaker 1: They're true.
Speaker 2: His website exists so it can be
screenshotted and posted onto bigger platforms,
Facebook and Twitter places that he
has been banned from. He wants to be
able to tweet. This is his way to tweet.
Speaker 1: All right. Anyway, so I think
you guys get what's going on. This this is a
what's great about this is the right. Lives in
an imaginary world and one of the totally fantasy
world beliefs that the right has constructed about
social media obviously that right wingers are
being overwhelmingly censored and depressed by
the jackbooted terms of service moderators or
whatever the case may be, but also that there's
just a massive demand from right wingers for
a so-called free speech platform, and that as
soon as one is available, they're going to flock
to it right away. Twitter was copied over into
truth a truth central. It's just a clone. It looks
just like Twitter. They just copied it. So when it
comes to functionality, you would think that if
there was really such a demand, that wouldn't
be an impediment to people going over the truth.
But people aren't doing it, and it's because there
isn't actually demand for that. I hope that it
fails and it seems to be going in that direction